what is the one tool that every 3d
artist literally can't create without
computers
and not just any old computer no because
3d art calls for some high-end system
requirements if you slap bottom of the
barrel parts onto your rig you're going
to get bottom of the barrel results
think about it just like we continually
seek to understand and master our
various softwares i think it's equally
important to understand the hardware
that makes all of this stuff possible so
this video is for every eager artist and
even soon to be artists out there
looking to step up their hobby or even
career with a deeper understanding of
how these things work we'll be able to
build buy or upgrade a rig with
confidence now i just had this
incredible workstation sent to me by
puget so be sure to stick around to the
end to figure out how they can put
together your dream rig just for you did
you know there are eight main components
you'll need for your 3d workstation and
this little thing right here is the head
chef it's called a processor or a cpu
every single task on your pc is sent
through your cpu now cpus they have
cores and threads that determine how
many workers the head chef has to help
with these tasks and the clock speed
determines how fast those workers are
but more on the details of all these
parts later sticking with the kitchen
metaphor all the people and appliances
in our kitchen are grounded to the floor
or the motherboard the motherboard
simply acts as a central hub for every
single piece of hardware on your
computer to either connect to buy power
cables or direct connection now since
our head chef the cpu is running like
3.5 billion laps a second he's going to
work up a little sweat and that's what
these bad boys are for they're cpu
coolers it's going to cool off your cpu
on tough days when you're rendering
simulating or just crunching numbers
it's literally your head chef's personal
air conditioning assistant now we got
ram ram or random access memory is
another piece of hardware that directly
connects to the motherboard and it's
essentially your easy to access
inventory slots ram temporarily stores
the data you're using close by to keep
your work efficient the more ram you
have the more inventory slots you have
and if you don't have enough ram you'll
essentially have to discard useful items
or data in order to make room for the
next most important thing also keep in
mind that this is temporary storage when
you restart your pc this cache will be
wiped so storage is the opposite it also
stores files but takes a bit longer to
access them when i say longer i mean
maybe a handful of seconds depending on
which drive you're using so there are
three types of storage drives the first
and slowest is your standard hard drive
they rely on moving parts solid state
drives are a bit faster they have no
moving parts but the nvme drives now
those connect directly to your
motherboard and are the fastest choice
for file storage also the most expensive
your storage drives are basically the
drawers cabinets and shelves in the
kitchen versus counter space which is
kind of like ram that makes grabbing
tools instant next up we have the power
supply now the power supply is what
provides electricity to all the parts
inside our computer without the power
supply you have a chunky paperweight
yeah you already know what this looks
like it's a gp it's a graphics card
all right it might be one of the most
important pieces of your 3d workstation
and unfortunately it's likely the most
expensive piece too
especially in today's market the gpu is
essentially a specialized mini computer
that does a number of things mainly
processing video feeds it turns all the
data and stuff that goes through your
cpu and turns it into a visual thing
that you're looking at on your monitor
the reason it's so important for us 3d
artists is because it allows us to see
what we're creating in real time and the
better your gpu the more of your 3d art
you can see at once
and finally we have the case itself it
houses all of the hardware of course but
also keeps things cool by ensuring
everything has enough space to breathe
it even comes with little panels and
windows for fans to keep things cool
okay so we talked about all the parts
generally but let's get into why
one cpu is better than another why one
gpu is more expensive than another a
processor's performance is generally
measured by three things cores threads
and clock speed the more cores a
processor has the more tasks it can work
on at the same time cpu-based render
engines like arnold and v-ray would
render just about two times faster on a
32 core cpu versus a 16 core cpu each
core is essentially a worker crunching
away on the task at hand now threads are
essentially ways that the cores can
multitask the more threads you have the
more things your cores can do at once a
higher clock speed simply equates to
more efficient workers now gpu
performance is measured by a lot of
stuff but the most important thing for
me personally is vram more video ram
means you can add more models more
simulations more materials more
everything to your 3d scenes and view it
all in real time running out of vram in
the middle of a project is basically
like running out of toilet paper
as far as tech specs go unreal engine
blender and c4d each call for their
individual vram minimums but the more
the better the nvidia quadro rtx 6000
has 24 and the a6000 has 48. this card
alone has unlocked my ability to create
larger scenes in 3d back in the day i
was working on a gtx 1070 and i think i
got some good renders out with this
1070. you don't have to go all out
right at the gates invest in yourself
over time invest in your career over
time
all right so let's talk about storage
the main difference between our three
hard drive options is really storage
space
you know a two terabyte ssd is gonna
cost more than a 500 gigabyte ssd so a
great rule to live by is to install your
operating system and programs on an ssd
while everything else lives on a basic
hard drive the idea is to speed up boot
and launch times by reserving a faster
drive for the important programs and
your operating system you can go a step
further and reserve another ssd for
cache data or go a step further and take
those two ssds upgrade them to nvme
drives the fastest drives your current
projects and most used files can go on
ssds and reserve everything else for the
standard hard drives so ram the main
difference in price between two ram
sticks will basically be capacity you
have a two gigabyte stick or you have a
16 gigabyte stick one's more expensive
than the other do you have one 16 gig
stick or do you have four of them you're
gonna spend more money on four obviously
ram is one of those pieces of hardware
where more is usually better you can go
overboard with it your computer may not
use all of it so you would just have
unused ram sitting there but it's better
than not having enough ram important
note on the power supply you want to
make sure that your power supply has
enough wattage to power your entire
computer the difference between a cheap
one
and a good one
is reliability that's the first thing is
reliability you have to have a reliable
power supply as far as cases go a crappy
case will be cramped and will barely
have any support for fans all right you
want to have a case that has room to
breathe that has enough air flow to cool
your parts off you don't want stuff to
be sweating in these things you want
them to be running as cool as possible
but remember
specs are important but i'd rather have
a part that is 10 slower and not crashed
than a part that's 10 faster and blue
screen my computer it doesn't matter if
you buy an overclock gpu or a super
cheap power supply if your hardware
isn't reliable they will be headache on
your rig on your life it'll just make
things suck you'll be wasting money as
3d artists we need a stable system
especially if your job counts on it for
those of you who would prefer to hire
professionals like puget to put together
your dream rig let me tell you how
awesome it was to work with these guys
the first thing you'll do is talk with a
professional about your specific needs
you tell them what programs you use what
kind of work you want to do on your pc
and what your job revolves around so for
my rig i told them i need to view
complex 3d scenes in real time and
render those scenes with as little wait
time as possible i need to process photo
scans quickly i need to quickly edit
high-res photos as well as 6k footage
without lag and with that they put
together a rig based on my needs gave me
daily updates on its build progress and
once completed shipped it out next day
it came with a folder of booting
instructions different info on my rig a
direct number to their tech support
service and they even threw in a bunch
of spare cables i might need in the
future i couldn't recommend it more to
people who need a trusted team of
professionals to build them a reliable
rig so if you're thinking of going this
route click the link below and chat with
a puget professional to see if a custom
rig makes sense for you also in the
description i included a bare bones 3d
workstation to keep the price as low as
possible i know this can get super
pricey for y'all and i just want to help
you get as much information on this
stuff as possible so that you can get
creating better stuff as fast as
possible if you learned something new
consider subscribing for more
educational deep dive content for
filmmakers and 3d artists and leave a
comment below if you have any questions
best of luck to you on your creative
journeys and i'll see you all soon peace
[Music]
you